stanislas denis emmanuel martin bertrand
à l'an 2000 voudrait 35 ans
croyez vous que le téléphone fera
toujours partie de votre vie oui pensez
que c'est utile
pouvez-vous supposer comment il
fonctionnera beaucoup changé bien et
bien je vous propose d'anticiper d'une
vingtaine d'années lundi de votre bureau
vous pouvez transmettre une lettre ou un
document à l'un de vos confrères
distants de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres
cette opération s'effectue en une minute
c'est la télécopie attention
[Musique]
oh
le mardi vous désirez appelez-la de vos
fournisseurs vous composer son numéro
par exemple 5 106 64 59
mais ça sonne occupé avant de raccrocher
vous mettez son numéro en mémoire et
maintenant vous raccrocher quand la
ligne sera libre c'est votre poste de
téléphone qui va rappeler votre
correspondant automatiquement dès que la
libye sera libre ça va sonner
vous décrochez et vous pouvez lui parler
emmanuel est en week end chez ses
parents qui possèdent un visiophone en
appelant de chez eux il peut voir ses
correspondants je vois la non embauche
peu un peu plus par là bas je sais je
vais passer un document pour voir
j'attends toujours que ça
mais je n'entends jamais personne
[Musique]
tout cela est très pratique mais il y
avait mieux encore c'est le domaine que
nous offrent les ordinateurs car
évidemment il fallait s'y attendre
en l'an 2000 les ordinateurs écrivent et
parle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]